wir essen einfach viel zu viel fleisch
und dieser fleischkonsum zerstörte ihr
die fleischproduktion verbraucht zu viel
fläche zu viel wasser und produziert
unglaubliche abgase jetzt den clixoom
zeit entwickeln mit elisa von live auf
der erde ist der fleischkonsum in den
letzten 40 jahren um das dreifache
gestiegen
immer mehr menschen essen immer mehr
fleisch inzwischen sind es 300 millionen
tonnen jedes jahr tendenz steigend
und die folgen sind fatal inzwischen
werden drei viertel der weltweiten
landwirtschaftlichen flächen für die
fleischproduktion genutzt
im amazonas gebiet sind dafür riesige
flächen urwald gerodet worden
pro hektar wird doch jetzt deutlich
weniger co2 gespeichert
acht tonnen sind es pro hektar der
urwald speicherte noch 200 tonnen
das war mehr als das zwanzigfache dort
wird unter anderem soja als tierfutter
angebot auch für europäische nutztiere
üble nebenwirkungen durch die
großflächige anwendung des herbizids
glyphosat kommt es vermehrt zu
fehlbildungen bei neugeborenen die
fleischproduktion verbraucht aber noch
zusätzliche ressourcen so benötigt die
produktion von einem kilogramm fleisch
bis zu 16 kilogramm getreide und achtung
festhalten
16.000 liter wasser das ist wirklich
eine riesenmenge zum vergleich um ein
kilogramm karotten herzustellen werden
130 liter wasser benötigt und für ein
kilo kartoffeln sind es 900 liter früher
war der sonntagsbraten noch etwas
besonderes
heute gibt es morgens mittags abends
fleisch fleisch kostet immer weniger
bezogen auf die löhne
weil es auch immer billiger produziert
wird inzwischen wird fleisch industriell
hergestellt 2011 eröffnete in wietze ein
geflügelschlachthof in dem bis zu 259
millionen hühner in der woche
geschlachtet werden
259 millionen und das hat folgen für die
umwelt so schätzt die
welternährungsorganisation der uno die
fau dass die weltweite fleischproduktion
rund 18 prozent der co2 emissionen
8 der weltweite transport verkehr
dagegen nur 13 prozent
neben der produktion den transport und
der lagerhaltung produzieren die tiere
auch selbst eine menge kohlendioxid
einfach beim ausatmen
hinzu kommen erhebliche methan mengen
die die tiere ausstoßen also
sprichwörtlich furzen
das methangas ist 20 mal
klimaschädlicher als co2 und tiere
stoßen ein drittel der auf unserem
planeten entstehende methan gase aus und
es gibt noch eine menge mehr
nebenwirkung in der massentierhaltung
müssen unmengen an antibiotika
eingesetzt werden sie führen zur
antibiotikaresistenz von immer mehr
bakterien gegen die dann irgendwann
nichts mehr hilft zu viel fleisch ist
auch nicht gut für unsere gesundheit
es kann ein herzinfarkt auslösen steht
unter dem verdacht darmkrebs zu
verursachen und viel mehr
der deutsche isst im schnitt 60 5
kilogramm fleisch
das ist das dreifache der empfohlenen
menge der deutschen gesellschaft für
ernährung
aber auch die vegetarische ernährung ist
nicht unbedingt gesund
nach neuesten studien werden vegetarier
öfter krank als menschen die sich
gemischt ernähren
andererseits gibt es genügend
pflanzliche produkte die die nährstoffe
enthalten die auch im fleisch vorhanden
sind es ist also nicht so einfach
was meint ihr denkt ihr auch dass wir
weniger fleisch essen sollten oder ist
das alles nur wieder panikmache der ökos
diskutiert es unter diesem video hier
klicken für das letzte video werden
jetzt aliens gefunden und hier gehts zum
klick zum blog unbedingt ansehen
und hier findet ihr das video zum
dramatischen klimawandel der uns durch
die abschwächung der jetstreams droht
spannende themen also da kann es nur
noch heißen bis dann bleibt dran